let's stick to the phones we'll go next
to our caller from the 786 area code
call it from 786 what's your name where
are you calling from and what's on your
mind
hello David can you hear me we can hear
ya speak up though you're a little low
and tell us your name - uh hi my name is
Danny from Miami Florida great hey by
the way other things how are things in
Miami what would the hurricane I'm sort
of tentatively supposed to be down in
Miami in December and is it is it are
things okay things are pretty flooded I
mean my neighborhood got a pretty nicely
he rattled by the UH by the hurricane uh
the whole trees down tree fell on my
neighbor's car so yeah not great
Howard's on though what would that power
is on powers on data service is still
not back if I'm calling through a Wi-Fi
right now okay
got it all right what's on your mind so
I wanted to ask you um with sort of the
rise of the far-right who the Western
Hemisphere I guess you can say what do
you think is the best way for the left
to sort of curtail that and kind of uh I
guess you could say regain the range
should we debate them punch them what do
you what do you think I don't think that
we should punch I do think that it makes
sense you know it's always tough when
you when you ask well what's the best
way to fight back against a particular
set of ideas because number one it's not
always there's not one method that is
the best for everybody right so
depending on one's position sort of
within society and their level of
knowledge and comfort and where you work
where you live etc there are different
ways that individuals can activate
against movements that they find to be
despicable vile and disgusting which
many of these movements certainly
qualify as so number one I think that
any time that the opponents to these
far-right movements turn to violence or
aggression they are hurting themselves
now you can make a moral case right
there are people who say no you can
morally make the case that Nazis deserve
to be
punched let's not even debate that lets
just agree or at least realize that if
you do that you are going to deal Ajith
oh my to D legitimize your side of the
debate and it really shouldn't be much
of a debate so you don't want to concede
anything by being the the side that goes
first to physical violence that's number
one number two debating debating is a
complex thing because there are debates
that merely by Nate by virtue of
agreeing to have a debate you are to
some degree legitimizing what you are
debating against in other words if an
idea really is so silly that it's not
worthy of being debated against that
means too many people that it's not that
worthwhile to even consider if there are
all of a sudden prominent debates with
white supremacists or extreme rightist
or whatever in a sense it might appear
as though that legitimizes their points
of view that's not always the case
though if you have people in media and
we do opposition debates with some
frequency and the context clearly is
like when I interview a white
supremacist the context is obviously I
don't agree with them and I'm coming in
prepared to sort of expose the
weaknesses in the arguments then I think
that there is some benefit to that but
as you can probably hear me saying Danny
there's no one-size-fits-all response
and I know that there have been a few
prominent articles that say you know one
view is ignore the far-right estándar
love the events that they throw just
completely ignore it and then there are
others who say terrible idea do not
ignore them because that's how they
slowly will gain more and more support
and before you know it these are
movements that will have some power so
unfortunately I don't think there's one
answer as to what to do but I think it's
really important not to be sort of
goaded or or suckered into acting in
ways that are going to be perceived as
de legitimizing the opposition movement
that's a really bad idea
yeah I I think I I agree with you there
I just you know I've read up on
some interesting articles that talk
about the absurdity of fascism basically
the this sort of uh Ned hiren stew
having an honest debate it's more about
you know presenting a strongman message
and it's a very hard idea to argue
against because you're coming to the
table with neo facts evidence whatever
you're trying to do to sway T yeah the I
guess you could say centrist and then
here comes someone who is touting a
different utilizing rhetoric to do
essentially bring people to their side
and so let's do you know I wanted also
beta today sometimes we think that if we
just hit people over the head with facts
then clearly they'll see that our facts
are right but as we've seen with climate
change and climate science it doesn't
really work that way so that that can be
dangerous not dangerous in any kind of
sense beyond just it can backfire yeah
all right Danny thanks so much for the
call very much appreciate it great to
hear from you